mais jamais une au travail de la maison
à temps plein ça lui est ingénieur dans
une grande entreprise s'ils passent une
grande partie de ses journées en
vidéoconférence donc sur internet
donc il faut une stabilité
il faudra peut-être c'était aussi
il a d'abord utilisé les services
d'explorer net avec une antenne
satellite fixe c'était vraiment c'était
postale les problèmes de connexion il
s'est donc tourné vers bell mobilité
plus fiables mais beaucoup plus cher ça
fonctionne très bien je me suis jamais
plaint de ce système le ça coûtait 300 à
400 dollars par mois dépendamment de la
consommation
depuis décembre et se branche au réseau
star lingli satellite dillon mosques
plus le temps encore de l'installer sur
la toiture l'équipement lui a coûté au
total 820 dollars mais sa facture qui
oscillait entre 300 et 400 dollars est
passé à 150 dollars par mois on
économise dans le sens d'or par mois
béja mais habite au bout d'un rang notre
dame de la paix il vit donc à la
campagne mais quand même seulement à un
peu plus d'une heure d'ottawa au québec
250 mille foyers n'avaient toujours pas
accès à internet haute vitesse vers
dernier une situation qui désavantage
les citoyens des régions rurales selon
ce spécialiste en moins d'occasions de
poids participer à l'évolution
d'économies parce qu'il pourrait
peut-être partir des services et des
produits à partir de la région mais si
on parle internet haute vitesse sont
probables d'interagir avec le vrai
marché de du sud le gouvernement le goût
s'est engagé à corriger cette iniquité
c'est que tout le monde soit branché
d'ici 2022 la fibre optique sera utilisé
dans la grande majorité des foyers mais
il faudra se tourner vers les satellites
pour brancher les ménages plus isolé
dans beaucoup de régions vraiment
heureuse puisque permet les nouveaux
satellites qui sont en train de
développer ce qu'on va pouvoir aussi
offrir un service de téléphonie mobile
d'occulter
les sexes a lancé jusqu'à maintenant
2000 satellite et son réseau starling
devrait en compter douze mille d'ici
cinq ans de son côté la canadienne
télésat compte mettre en orbite trois
satellites
les premiers lancements sont prévus dans
deux ans mais l'entreprise perna
compléter son financement des retards
qui laisse le champ libre aux
concurrents étrangers il se marie claude
morin radio-canada notre dame de la paix